well hello everyone so I'm rich hummed
up a academic my background is in
business intelligence software both on
like making it and being a consumer of
it and this is kind of my hobby
and I worked with and as I'd serve is
that Berkeley from the paper that we
always got some attention but I'm just
going to throw all the technical details
before I get into the wider picture so
we've been extremely focused just on
this narrow feature of YouTube the
recommendations so when you watch your
video you'll see on the right if you're
under stop beneath if you're on mobile a
list of videos that is recommending and
the very one at the top that will
autoplay next by default unless you turn
off the autoplay feature and the rest
are just presented to you seemingly
fairly and not gross but I think it's
actually quite an important that's a big
effect in terms of police so Google
three search on YouTube has a lot of
soft power I don't think they went they
sort out that but that's what they have
said they can influence people's beliefs
quite easily and in a way that is hard
to detect
so for YouTube in particular 18 percent
of US adults according to Pew watch do
two for at least part of the news data
and 70 percent of the watch time on
YouTube is from the recommendations that
was just one marketing person from
Google back when they were boasting
about this kind of thing but if it's
anywhere near that that's just still a
lot the other aspect to this is Google
is not transferring all about the
recommendations of the way the algorithm
works in detail their transparency
reports they're just more like marketing
documents so they contain top-level
numbers showing you know
percent how well they've been working on
those things and I think the media is
often hostile and irrationally so
towards check now so in that environment
like it makes sense that all the
communications very strategic containing
very little information that they can be
called out on so they don't share things
like the aggregate statistics on
recommendations that they've shown to
people and for creators on YouTube
there's a lot of decisions that get made
that everyone else just finds out when
they happen so the people making a
living it can be difficult working on
YouTube if you get copyright strikes the
videos getting monetize or video gets
removed and it's very much like the
weather you don't know always you don't
always know why it happens and it's very
it's quite hard to predict given how
frequently they changed the rules it's
definitely in the public interest to
understand what Google's influence on
politics is now that's historically
always been a really keen interest on
Venice in media coverage of politics so
in the u.s. there was the Fairness
Doctrine which was an attempt to
regulate ballots in the variety of views
they get out on controversial topics in
an Australia we have rules about equal
coverage to candidates and media
ownership but none of these are
purchasing very relevant today given the
Internet and I think we should be
skeptical about the practicalities of
you know government regulation working
in practice so I think it's definitely
an important role of researchers and
journalists to discover and report on
the impact that YouTube has and you know
any massive content platforms and then
an informed public can pressure YouTube
to change for the better and I think
that's naive they seem to be reacting
and responding to public pressure but
there's problems with I think research
of journalists in this area to come back
to at the end his bit of technical
details about how we collected YouTube
down I've got a I've got anis your
function which is just a little program
that runs in the cloud and the advantage
is that you just pay for the time that
runs and it can be triggered based on
things that happen or just on the
schedule so that's the way I'm using it
and it launches a bunch of contain
instances which are basically like
lightweight virtual machines designed
just for a single application with its
dependencies and that launch is about 10
seconds and there's about there's 11 of
them and so yeah there's a little bit
I've just pay for the time that those
from they read from the YouTube API and
for channel details and it scrapes the
YouTube website to get video statistics
and recommendations and then it stores
all that data and shore up storage which
is basically like a file system in the
cloud
most people use AWS for these so if
you're using AWS the equivalent would be
lambda function watching Fargate
containers and then storing in history
then once we've collected the data
thanks that was transforming it for
analysis I use data form this so I guess
all of this is an alternative to what
most academics would use is like an hour
or a Python script data form
it runs SQL in a warehouse and what it
adds just from doing that manually is it
understands the dependencies between
them so I can create quite a complicated
series of steps
and understands the dependencies between
them and runs them in parallel in the
right order and all excuse in the white
house and there's some really good
technology Google has big query and I
use snowflake both of them I'm really
good executing this at scale and you
just pay for your compute and the
storage for those queries that you're on
so ends up being cheap or you can manage
how cheap it is by the way your honor
after that runs I use an a script and
c-sharp scripts the Oscar is to perform
statistical models and my sea shell
script just gets final aggregated
results which are then used for the
visualizations are used whoa
which is it's a it's a tool that lets
you query the database using the power
of the database to quickly build
analysis and visualization and the
website especially later that's built
using Gatsby which builds a static
website and the advantage of a static
website is that you can host it in a lot
of different places and it runs very
fast so in my case I'm using as you
static web sites and it's distributed
using cloud players so when you load up
our website it will be cached somewhere
near your city and this know if there's
no like web servers running code it will
still done in the browser for the code
on the website missing tribe script just
like JavaScript but it's better compiled
time checking when you were adding it
and you get nice in documentation and
intellisense reacts which is really
popular way to do interactive interfaces
all run from the client zone and d3
which is it's a visualization library
but it's really low-level
so if you're going for really polished
in particular ways presenting works more
specialized
you really need to go down to that low
level to get exactly what you want since
then terms of data collection is not as
easy as it should be YouTube definitely
doesn't help very much with this so
their API we get channel stance but for
everything else we've we're actually
scraping the website they provide this
information through the API and that's
the way we started this so from November
last year to October this year we were
using the YouTube API but you should
actually blocked our access because they
restrict as part of the agreement that
you don't store all this data for longer
than 30 days and you don't use more than
one key so we we needed both of those
things so there was no way around it
when we scraped the YouTube website
within about 50 to 400 requests will get
blocked and to get around that we fall
back to using residential proxy a
residential proxy service which
basically has home IP addresses so going
through Comcast AT&T those residential
style connections and that means that
you too can't block all of them so as
soon as that bucket we fall back to the
next one and there's millions of them
maybe it cost us but we can always get
as much data as you know want going
through that technique because of a
collecting data every day and we're
trying to get a lot to have a good
representation about recommendations
over time if we did requests in serial
we probably wouldn't even get enough
data if it ran all day but it's a very
simple problem to make parallel so we
launched lots of different command line
tools in the cloud contain instances
which then inside them run a lot in
parallel and depending on language
issues they usually live
this concept of tasks that's what the :
c-sharp in node that we call promises
and Python I think they're called
futures and that allows you to do lots
of requests in parallel without creating
a threat for each one which will make a
lot slower and usually you need to use a
library on top of those to manage a
whole collection of things to run in
c-sharp its we I used on net TTL is out
of flow and I quickly try to find one in
Python to explain it but I didn't find
it I'm sure it exists you can look it up
all this codes online so if you are
interesting something similar you can
refer to that and it began reach
container summarizes data into a
compress JSON he'll file
I used this instead of CSVs
because it's just much easier to
serialize from your program you can have
a much richer structure so you can
facade filled sub documents and you can
change it over time and it doesn't break
as quickly as a few T's in CSV and a lot
of the new platforms support a team so
the statistics for my collection about
every every day we read it about to give
up gigabyte it's just a text alert any
JavaScript of the the images so it's a
favorite just in text we send four
thousand requests 94% end up falling
back to using the properties I say that
thirty Greek West per second and it
takes about thirty or fifty minutes to
complete most of the costs for running
this come from those proxies and the
warehouse depending on how much we use
it so the first step when we actually to
do the study we need to work out which
channels to look at so we were
considering any channel that had more
than ten thousand subscribers and how to
focus on United States politics
no cultural commentary approximating
like more than 30 percent of their
content focus on that and to discover
channels we started with an objective
criteria like sighting from the official
official lists or tags for news and then
finding recommendations but we found it
was difficult it was having a lot of
false positives and also missing a lot
of obvious channels that should have got
so we actually just adopt a variety of
strategies so looking at other research
and looking at things like social blade
and following the recommendations that
YouTube made to get the most coverage we
could so we try to it's not to gauge how
much we have evolved the channels that
might meet the criteria but we think
we've got most of them and then we
classify them so to do that we had three
views go through every channel by tight
800 of them watch the content and then
categorized them in a variety of ways
independently so one way we categorize
them was either left center or right the
ones the channels that were deadly
mainstream news would be listed on three
websites media bias factor or at Fontes
media and if they were in those we would
just take the majority view from those
two science if they weren't we had more
subjective criteria that people went
through then people classified them with
you know two for calling self tags which
are properties about the channel
channels we think of relevant so things
like are they state-funded and what is
the ideology are they're libertarians
conspiracy theorists social people
promoting social justice things like
that and then from that we took the
majority view from all of our viewers
analyzed how reliable they were and we
derived a group which is a simple one to
one category with channels that
so the tags who optimized for reviewers
that's fine content very concretely and
specifically and this group is more to
fit into public discussion about
ideology and YouTube so you can you can
look at the details of that in the study
or on github and the results where in
terms of the categories on the Left
we're showing the relevant Bayley views
between those different groups that we
categorized at the top center left for
mainstream media part of them left for
median partisan rat in smaller groups
and on the right you can see the total
amount of channels and it's interesting
they don't don't correlate so a lot of
the smaller groups have a lot of
channels which is represents the supply
of content that's on YouTube I think
people get confused when they talk about
the proliferation of different groups on
YouTube they often ignore the amount of
views and concentrator than the amount
of content going to show you our
visualization this is public you can go
to reckful internet have a look at it
and it shows a know you of what we've
done so each bubble here is the channel
this size is the number of daily views
that channel gets and they're positioned
according to physics basically so it's
called a force directed graph and they
each channel repels each other by
default and then they're attracted to
each other by the percentage of
recommendations between them so channel
is close to each other have a lot of
mutual recommendations so you can't rely
on the axis like left-right up-down
doesn't mean anything and each time you
either update the data it would look
quite different but the distance between
the channels basically remain Samar when
you do that
I on the right we're showing the flows
of impressions between them so we're
calling an impression when you see a
recommendation or a video this the
amount of users that video converted
into impressions of that and on the
right is where they're going to so where
the recommendation de grips that
recommendation goes to so example to
understand this CNN you can see the
lines here highlighting where CNN's
recommendations go to come from and on
the right is the summary of those flows
and then in the chart if you want to
change between different ways of
splitting this up you can do that and
you can highlight groups so here I'm
looking at conspiracy theories and if
you zoom in you can see what channels
they are largest being the next news
that work and full-dress of watching
both promoting things like 9/11 being a
government conspiracy
so they there to analysis the destroys
simply the recommendations from the
groups as a percentage of all the
recommendations to other groups I'll
just point out a few patterns you can
see the diagonal line from the top left
to the bottom right and that's basically
the bubbles that people are in so if
you're on Senate if you're watching a
center-left NSN video 51% of the
recommendations just other ones in that
group it's an open question whether
that's more bubbly than traditional
media but it's definitely definitely
exists now the pattern in to look at
would be the provocative anti JW
conspiracy theories religious
conservatives libertarians the amount of
the percentage of the recommendations
that go to the partisan riot stands out
and then along the column lists the
considers to produce a little bit just
sorry you receive the Socialists white
identitarian mi rice you can see they're
very much black so they're not getting
many recommendations from the other
groups so this is a very simple and easy
to understand why you're sending this
data but when you think about what a
neutral that Gotham would look like it
would be one that recommends channels
proportional to the views that already
gets so it has very little influence and
that would look like the bigger group so
more bubbly or that the smaller groups
are being disadvantaged when does
actually the case so we analyzed solve
that problem we analyzed using only net
impressions this is how we get to there
so every day we collect recommendations
and new starts for videos so we can work
out how many views are on a video on a
particular day so I could do a really
simple example I've got video a with
five thousand views for the twenty
and this presenting video BCD so we give
those five thousand views as impressions
towards the other videos so count that
as a sending an impression from video a
and after there's other videos video B's
the only one that has an impression back
to a video a but it has 30,000 views so
saying that it receives three thousand
impressions so from that if this was our
entire data set we would say that video
a sent fifteen receive 30k impressions
which is another 15,000 received and
that's an impression advantage of 100%
so if that's clear and that is the
context for this chart which shows the
way did the way Google tips the scales
just of who they adventuring they
disadvantage from this groups so we can
see cinema center-left MSM although it's
got the most amount of use it's it's
neither advantage or disadvantage in
november/december which this this data
is for the pot is in left and right our
advantage by the algorithm and then my
see the other groups of disadvantage in
particular the borderline content and
conspiracy theorist yet hardly any views
anymore and I've got an animation over
time so there's all our data we have
it's a little bit noisy you can see in
about as a cycling through what we can
focus on conspiracy theorist in April it
really starts to change
so getting too late so this is the
beginning in the data set conspiracy
theorists about getting equal to the
views and then it starts being neutral
and Google's started limiting them by
April and then even more so as time goes
on
so we split those other ways to split
out this data we looked at the Left
Front bias and they're fairly neutral in
that respect so they're not they're not
they're not been everything one side of
that spectrum Olivo but there's a large
mainstream bias so mainstream media
receives 20% extra and independent
YouTube channels severely disadvantaged
missing link mean a little bit
disadvantage missing link media is just
full profit relatively mainstream but
not quiet channels so this is in detail
the flows between each group to each
other I go through that but I've
summarized all of this which is more
than a million net flow per day so you
can see that social justice channels
losing a lot of impressions towards
center-left mainstream media or the part
of the left and the more borderline or
smaller groups that are you might
consider right-wing go to what's the
partisan right leaking a bit to the left
in the mainstream media it was quite
different to the story that all common
knowledge about the way the algorithm is
influencing views on YouTube and there's
a certain story that I think this debunk
so the story goes like this
it's just a rabbit hole in YouTube to
increase revenue and keep you watching
YouTube recommends increasing
increasingly extreme content this is how
they have you believe as many possible
things before breakfast and is kind of
intuitive for most people I think
because when you come from reading the
newspaper or watching cable news the TV
there is a much more diverse amount of
quality and also the spectrum follows
because there
some really great stuff as well so that
stands out to people but the claim goes
well beyond that it's that it's giving
you extra seen increasingly extreme
content for lady and I think that's
false and I think the journalism has
been biased in this area so I think part
of it is an anti tech bias
the technology companies taken much the
advertising revenue from media and at
the same time people's information bias
and much more decentralized now and
media of trying to keep their influence
by decreasing the status by disparaging
them I think the other effect is just
selection effects the martial people
about the dangers of technology get the
most attention and the most shareable
information about it and from from
journalism so from research I think
there are similar effects I'll give you
some examples the peer-reviewed research
in this area will describe viewers that
move towards the far right as being
infected this language like that when
they look at radicalization pathways
they only look at it towards right-wing
they don't look at the other way and
they only look for evidence of that so
they'll look for recommendations to war
over channels but not from right-wing
channels to left-wing or not from
extreme right-wing for less extreme ones
so it just it definitely seems like
everyone's trying to confirm the
existing beliefs there's not enough
curious research about what is actually
happening and then reporting on on that
as well
one of the main criticisms of what we
did was that we use anonymous data to
collect so when you get recommendations
um they're personalized so things like
the location that you're from and your
history your viewing history and other
things are taking into account so
everyone's we different um the reason
everyone would like to do this in this
area but it's very difficult so there's
two reasonable ways to try and get at
this you could simulate pretty typical
users might get a representative sample
of real um likes I'll put some type
of Google accounts that have had a
history somewhat different as the people
and does a representative even the
United States and then look at the
recommendations that they get but that
that really entails the little work and
also a lot of assumptions about what are
what those uses would be what the
history would be and whether that's
representative the other way would be
you can you can get people to sir you
get people to install browser extensions
and they record what they actually see
from the recommendations from their real
YouTube join the problem with that is
it's very difficult to get people to
install something like that and be
willing to send you all the information
over lunch for your time may be
difficult also to make that
representative so our working assumption
is that personalization leverage out
so because purpose even though it's
personalized for different users unless
they're really tilting the scales in
some weird way or changing the algorithm
with personalization it should be about
the same so given that what they shot
when you is the average of views to
what's popular for what you're watching
now so I'm explaining this really badly
but but you get the idea should it
should average out and the way
working to try and see whether that is
the case is we're comparing creators
private analytics so if you're a
creditor of videos on YouTube you can
actually see the other channels that are
recommending you and you get the real
impression so the amount of times people
have actually seen the video so if we
can get a large enough amount of credits
the sentences we should be able to gain
idea if it is the same or if there are
systematic differences what they are and
try and take that into account as it
stands now we see a lot of correlation
so when we saw the change in
recommendations to conspiracy videos we
then saw the same those creators
complaining about the same thing a lot
of other things have happened over time
as correspondent so consider this the
most comprehensive study so far and it's
still an open question as to whether
that assumption is correct so all the
code of licenses as an MIT licit license
so you can use it what a happy wish
aggregated data you can down low if you
want the full data you just need a
snowflake account and then I'll share
that with you and you'll get updated
daily statistics the reason why I can't
share that with files I'm not sharing
with files because it's up to about 40
gigs and it's just not practical
and you'll also want the latest so
you're not trying to hide it for me
it's just you you ought to use a
database and I'm looking for grants and
collaboration I've really enjoyed
working as an independent research for a
tiny amount of time and you know if I
don't get it money I'll continue running
it but going back to my normal job so
definitely reach out if you want to see
or if you know someone that would want
to see more if the type of research
we've done
so that's the end of my slides open up
to questions happy to do demos if
anything so tableau of how we classify
things or looking more to the
visualization anything you had one slide
that was a matrix of the groups that was
percent recommendations and I noticed
along the top horizontally the on the
very right most side there was one group
non-political but I didn't see them on
the labels vertically and I was just
wondering I was kind of interested in
the non-political groups and in
particular if you knew a news source
that was non-political the question was
there was a non political on the
horizontal axis but not on the vertical
on this slide that was percent
recommendation yeah yeah so in terms of
our data collection
it's just unfeasible to collect all of
the recommendations from all the
channels on YouTube so any kind of
recommendations from the political
channels in our data set so we don't
know we don't know what recommendations
are coming from channels outside but we
know ones are they going outside from
within does that make sense
not really but really what I'm
interested in is did you find YouTube
channels about news that were
non-political and what were they is that
with this last column is no no it's a
non-political channel what non-political
right yes yeah that's right so it's a
channel that when that's outside of our
dataset so we haven't got in our list of
political channels so it could be a
music video oh it could be cooking I
don't know I haven't actually looked at
what the norm
okay so we've looked at that list
to try and find extra political videos I
haven't like summarized which which type
of channels they want okay okay any
other questions he's now trying to give
you a class job yeah um so this is a non
technical question but I was just
wondering whether you have any thoughts
about what the Facebook recommendation
algorithm would be based on what you
have learned about the YouTube one
because obviously like there's been a
lot of news about Facebook influencing
elections or something to YouTube
question about Facebook have you looked
at Facebook recommendations or yours
like your thoughts about it
we haven't I can speculate it's slightly
different on Facebook because you've got
your newsfeed and they're deciding what
appears gee I think yeah I'm actually
kind of speculate so I don't actually
know very much for that we've really
focus just on YouTube so I'm not much of
a YouTube user but I gather that people
who are logged in aggregate
recommendations which are personalized
to them based on their other viewing are
these are all predefined channels am i
right
or yes I see but how does the
recommendation algorithm work for
individuals that watch content does it
put them in a bubble which is similar to
the stuff that they ordinarily watch or
does the throw in a little serendipity
just to give them a little diversity or
does it categorize them and lump them
into one of these categories that's the
closest to what they appear to be
watching did you look at any of that did
you you know create personas for any of
your people that you know create
personas for any of your channels that
might suggest how people get led
if they watch certain kinds of content
and we didn't we didn't do that
systematically because the difficulties
involved and the assumptions that we
have to make but we did do a few
experiments so we created a fresh
account and looked at conspiracy video
is just just into a sanity check to see
whether that personalization would mean
you get conspiracy recommendations that
you went that we went seeing when using
anonymous and they didn't but apart from
that no we haven't we haven't done any
systematic look while a users logged in
but looking at the way other
recommendation system works of
personalization works you can guess my
assumptions are that it's a lot to do
with what you've previously watched but
there'll be because the anonymous
recommendations of what people have
organically watched you'll have both
sides of the direction of influence
taking into account the average
anonymous recommendations so that person
like personalization should screw fairly
evenly both ways or Shamy and another
question I assume they use popularity or
recency as among the things that cause
them to recommend something that's not
true that's true yes yes that's true
that's what pew found that's what they
say they do that's what we found it's
it's vaguely interesting to me that you
didn't assume that they was trying to
maximise staying on YouTube as long as
possible as an advertising company yeah
well but we think that they do we assume
that they they try to get people to stay
on YouTube but we don't think that
recommending consistently extreme
content to get you to do that they're
recommending your content that they
think you will like the most
so there's an it was a form of the
algorithm probably before we started
which was based on one of the click
throughs for recommendations that which
is quite going to click bait but these
days algorithms based on other like
another combination of metrics how much
you watched the video you clicked on and
then think about surveys so it's also
based on how much those people liked the
videos that they watched so they've gone
on a whole more holistic approach now
that looks at are you going to enjoy the
next video you watch which is to get
advertising revenue but it's not as
nefarious I think as what the common
story is about it uh so my question is
whether or not you've done any analysis
regarding like a bias towards US News or
away from US News or if the the data
collection prevents that analysis we
just looked at US News so we don't
really know you the differences between
them I would like I think goodbye to
take this if we can find people to
collaborate is you look at other
countries like Brazil and IB Portugal
where it's a big impact in Australia we
don't actually as much of our politics
is on YouTube for whatever reason we can
shame your politics so I'll just try
asking this one more time I didn't ask
correctly before or explain it very well
I was just wondering did you find any
news groups that are non partisan news
does that even exist for them they
weren't interesting that wasn't as cool
oh there there are some but it's not as
yeah it's not as many as you would
expect just from my experience I like
PBS newshour that's pretty that's pretty
neutral good but my skis one way or
another like I think maybe the idea that
you can be that neutral is a bit naive
hello
I'm just curious how you order the axis
of the ordinates
why aren't they like weren't they
strictly why isn't this graph
symmetrical given you have the same
ordinance and axis on the same thing
then why wouldn't you have the highest
numbers in the upper left and going
monotonically yeah that's good all right
that's a good question it's because it's
the percent of total of the left group
that makes it asymmetrical does that
make sense
it sounds bias to me so if you add up
the percentages across the rows should
be about a hundred but that means you
don't get a symmetrical chart but it
makes sense in terms that's the best way
I think to display to get a sense of the
percent of recommendations from each
group and then the other chart
symmetrical because we're looking at the
total flows of net recommendations makes
sense okay well thank you very much it
was